[Musica]
bene
[Applauso]
è che se mi si sa cosa sta facendo la
festeggiamo il compleanno
chi si mi si sta festeggiando il
compleanno ma qualche armi a chi sei
mesi
non lo so 127
che sta succedendo
[Musica]
[Applauso]
il nostro libro i bustoni paurose kiir
ha regalato di walkie dobbiamo
riprendercelo se sapete che il libro ha
dei poteri e in mani sbagliate potrebbe
essere catastrofi soprattutto nelle mani
di ayew anche chi si disse dobbiamo
riprenderlo subito
sì ho troppa paura che qui ci dieta
soprattutto come vedi non c'è abbastanza
spazio quindi io vado a nascondermi
blocchiamo
[Musica]
vitale il solito fifone e ha voluto
andare a nascondersi di no e il solito
vi fonio va beh proverò a riprendere il
libro mentre lui è nascosto forse se mi
nascondo qui non mi vedranno quindi
mi metto qui dietro questo scivolo
comodo
[Musica]
ma che nasconde un po come
posso schiacciare un pisolino
ma
va
[Musica]
[Applauso]
cos'era questo rumore
niente c'è troppo sonno però
per fortuna non riescono
non riescono ad entrare 4
ok si sono liberati finalmente per
fortuna non possono entrare qua dentro
tiago al sicuro devo assolutamente
recuperare il mio libro storie paurose
avete visto l'hanno lasciato lì sul
trono del data parti a proposito grazie
da da forti per averci ospitato di nuovo
se volete festeggiare il vostro
compleanno assolutamente dovete
costeggiano 40 da porti perché è
bellissimo ha un sacco di giochi un
sacco di sale e ora presto continuiamo
la challenger dobbiamo recuperare il
libro storie paurose e voi ce l'avete
l'avete preso ripresi mini commenti se
l'avete preso ma vitale dove sarà ancora
l'idea posto ora che si sono allontanati
devo uscire da qua e cercare di non
essere breve
sarò anche waikiki stilisti non li vedo
più
molto strano c'è molto silenzio io provo
ad andare là dove c'era il trony e provò
a riprendermi il libro il mio libro
magari non c'è nessuno ne dubita ma
proviamo ok sembra che non ci sia
nessuno qua bene viali
è
[Musica]
non riuscivo mai a prenderlo meglio a
scappare
aiuto
ok se non riuscite a scappare questa
volta erano un po più lenti del solito
forse quando si illuminano gli occhi
puoi dire che sono più lenti ci sono a
chi vuol dire chisti misti che fanno la
guardia può trovare un'altra soluzione
per recuperare il libro devo distrarli
con qualcosa
guardate un palloncino ovvero a
distrarli con questo dopotutto è il
compleanno di chi si
missile farà piacere ricevere un
palloncino del suo colore ma chi guardi
che si mesi o un regalino per voi
dove siete pupazzi malefici
capisco
gli wally
chi simili vorrei fare uno scambio cioè
io vi do questo palloncino rosa e bohème
iridate il mio libro storie paurose cosa
ne pensate
guardate se non riuscite perché mi
stavano cercando world
io pensavo che voi non rispettare la
dentro ci riuscite
queste per te non mangiarli
sembra contenta
[Musica]
regalo per esamineranno
che succede
aspetta momento ma mimosa bene perché
questa reazione io ti ho fatto un regalo
brito problema perché mi stai seguendo
rete
[Musica]
prendiamo libro presi a questi qua
equilibro
preso
o no
[Applauso]
[Risate]
devo capire come uscire da qua e poi
devo riuscire a riprendere il mio libro
ma dov'è finito vitale potrebbe aiutarmi
[Musica]
chi è che chiusa la
eccomi manda me bisogno dalle 20 bene
perché minuto
massimo potere e dovere ferito
sto facendo oggi web fissi missiva
dietro perché mi è sembrato di vederne
scappare la dietro allora sono andato a
controllare ma sarà di mondi e che se
visti erano qua e mi hanno rifiuta qua
dentro
davvero
quindi ci sono due anche i luoghi 2
kissi missy no secondo me solo che non
li stavi cercando proprio per niente dai
sbrigati vivere ops liverani subito
scoperto gli sparano beh stavo dormendo
ceo adesso di libro seminario ha detto
stava acido antigua di stava dormendo di
lallo visto prima perché allora per
librarsi dietro liberarti aspetta
un martello con il martello sapri adesso
lo sfondamento
[Musica]
ci sono i sinistrati omologhi in giro
non solo non riuscita a prendere il
libro con insieme un piano vai a
nasconderti là dentro e richiama così
loro timori che se misti arriveranno li
a cercarti nel frattempo si io uscirò
qua fuori prenderò il libro poi ti
chiamo devi correre subito qua e li
chiudiamo qui ha detto colpa ce vò che è
pronto settore marittimo
lui mi nascondo ha detto
una volta che vitale chiama di walkie e
che sti visti io correrò di la prenderò
il libro e poi chiudere il cancello
evitare al mio tre piano di ok
123 il pd
oggi quasi guai
guai
ecco l'intervista comitato
misto non devo prendermi date preso
impegnarsi
il test ha chiamato scappiamo scappiamo
[Applauso]
[Musica]
giudizi ora vuoi che ti chiudi gli ho
detto noi abbiamo
il libro è il nostro adesso
[Musica]
bravo
questa parola
[Musica]
aiuto aiuto o c'è chi infatti che sta
comunque
già arrivato terremoto scappiamo
sappiamo
[Musica]
perché di questo
aiuto aiuto aiuto
mi sto prendendo per scappare
ci sono un costo non mi troverà mai un
po forse sì o forse meglio scappare via
[Musica]
a chi scappa con un che non mi stia
seguendo via via via
scappiamo
ma che cosa stai facendo o no mi sembri
cento qui dentro aiutatemi a trovare vie
d'uscita
dove posso andare
a cuba ci fa piacere da qui al momento
fabiano
no no no va bene io sto bene anche qui
ha lasciato anche una sedia per me
grazie sei molto gentile aspetterò
quindi che essere liberato allora che si
dopo prova a scappare spero tanto che
anita mi troverà mille berera dagli
waikiki me chiuso qua dentro verità ha
detto
guarda che se piccoli
tutto qui chissà dov'è anita ciao
ragazzi vitale è stato imprigionato da
vari luoghi devo riuscire a liberarlo
per liberarlo dovrà risolvere tutti gli
enigmi qua il parco giochi avete visto
dove siamo siamo al data parti grazie ad
da forti per averci ospitato di nuovo il
posto ideale se volete organizzare le
vostre feste di compleanno eventi e
bellissimo presto devo sbrigarmi a
trovare tutti gli indizi e tutti e
meccanismi per sbloccare vitale prima
che dilaghi
a chi va chi vuole mangiare vitale
comunque ho con me il mio libro storie
paurose che mi proteggerà o proposito è
ora disponibile in tutte le librerie
online voi l'avete preso ce l'avete già
scrivetelo nei commenti iniziamo subito
dobbiamo liberare evitare il prima
possibile se non avete ancora lasciato
un bivio se lasciati un mi piace qua
sotto perché se questo video raggiunge i
20 mila vi piazza e torneremo al dada
parti a fare un altro video
questo
seguitemi c'è qualche meccanismo qua
innanzitutto dobbiamo trovare il grado
pack così possiamo sbloccare tutti i
vari meccanismi e se per caso a chi vuol
chi mi seguirà userò e il libro e poi
vedrete come prezzo
andiamo
a
liberarmi
italo resisti lì nella prigione con a
khimki anzi viene impegnato a chi guardi
così almeno non verrà qua a prendermi ho
bisogno di un po di tempo per trovare
tutte le soluzioni ancora non ho trovato
il grappa da qua devo salire sopra allo
scivolo mi sono ricordata di mettere i
calzini antiscivolo
vediamo se ci riesco uffici volo
o no ogni volta a salire quando allo
scivolo e difficilissimo non posso
perdere tempo qua cercando di scali
dallo scivolo devo trovare un'altra
strada libro io topi con i tuoi poteri
credo che il libro non abbia poteri
antiscivolo vabbè andiamo in un'altra
strada prescrive
[Musica]
scattava tema che è arrivato qua è
presto detto
aiuto aiuto aiuto a dio voti alla sopra
noi dobbiamo passare da quel passaggio
lo giuro vedete quale un altro passaggio
per non passare dallo scivolo
forse mentre aspettare che a chi vuoi
che vada via
speriamo che evita le lodi stranka avete
visto quanto è oggi le anche white
riesce arrampicarti ovunque e poi e
silenzioso quindi potrebbe spuntare
fuori all'improvviso da qua
ho sentito il rumore
forse è andato via vediamo se non c'è
vera su ok ora possiamo proseguire nel
nostro percorso e cercare il gran pack
andiamo passiamo da qua
però che il grand funk sia qua sopra
altrimenti senza il grappa che non posso
risolvere gli enigmi chissà come sarà
vitale presso presto ecco qua siamo
nell'altra area prima di vuoti ha
eseguito vitale qua ma ora viene
rinchiuso dall'altra parte però forse
qua riusciamo a trovare qualcosa visto
che è passato a di waqif che quasi era
simbolo ma non riuscirò salita
vediamo che c'è qualcosa da sotto poi fa
non c'è niente non so se passare qua
oppure salire sopra allo scivolo anche
se probabilmente 20 vi
è
toccato qualcosa con i miei piedi
guardate guardate
che
però non ho nessuna delle mani non ho
nella mano blu nella mano rossa e quindi
in realtà non me ne faccio niente prima
e meglio che trovo le mani e
[Musica]
così a periodo per un le mani potrà
utilizzarle presto alla ricerca delle
mani ok ragazzi ho appoggiato il grappa
qua ora proverò a salire sopra vi
ricordate più vitale stava scappando in
quel tubo arancione giallo profonda re
lima gari troverò qualcosa
il libro sembra indicare proprio là
sopra andiamo
sbrighiamoci
sento dei rumori strani di sentito anche
voi
spero che non ci sia che i fuochi
hockeysti mistico
meglio
all improvvisa voglia di scendere non
continuare a salire la sopra da dove
salvare vitale dopo un bar e
non fatto più rumore forse è andato via
speriamo ci sia la mano qua o quella blu
o quella rossa
non vedo niente ancora
[Musica]
stato ormai non so come sia possibile
non avevamo mai visto a chi vuol di
dormire forse trent'anni o anche non lo
so normale come noi mangia dorme va in
bagno
non voglio immaginarmi come back o per
chi va chi sta proteggendo qualcosa di
prezioso
l'importante che abbiamo il libro con
noi per proteggerci
c'è la mano mi ha detto ho trovato
l'amore un blog
guardate
evviva ragazzi ho trovato l'oro blu
tutto grazie al libro che mi ha portato
qua ora manca solo la mano rossa
partendo
non riesci a postare il libro creato uno
li
abbiamo scoperto è sbloccato un altro
potere del libro
vado a prendere la mano
[Musica]
eccola qua ma l'ho presa
non so perché bassista bene dentro
questo tubo e così rilassante e come se
avessi improvvisamente dimenticato che
c'è un pupazzo malefico che mi sta
inseguendo
capitale ancora imprigionato la destra
devo sbrigarmi ok ragazzi sono tornata
con gioco preso il gran pack ora
carichiamolo con la nostra mano blu
siamo prontissimi a tirare la barra blu
che faccia da no penso che la dovremo
usare per qualche puzzle parla sarebbe
divertente tirarlo in faccia
l'importante è che io sempre il libro
con me che vi proteggerà presto
cerchiamo il puzzle da risolvere per
aprire la prossima area brunita bravo
hai fatto prendere la mano blu
guarda che per sbloccare il cancello
devi premere quello li guarda lo
guardano io sono qui tanto oppure a
seria con la sedia vi posso essere qui e
fare il tifo per te margherita fu
pulsante dunque il cancello ok vado
subito media voto per questo pulsante
blu premi il pulsante blu con la mano
più brava prova
guardate che quel pulsante blu devo
minarlo con la mano blu forse aprirà
quel cancello di cui stava parlando a
vitale e non so cosa troveremo là dentro
forse la mano rossa speriamo 3 2 1
avete sentito
il cancello 6 bloccato presto andiamo
prendiamo la mano rossa e poi forse
riusciremo a liberare vita aspetta
ricarichiamo nel caso che incontriamo
gli one meglio ora sono con te
ho preso ora sono non ho preso niente
volevo dire che ho sbloccato il pulsante
che mi hai detto quindi va verso
dovrebbe vendere solo nei loro scappò
visto che il primo cancello o torna
subito sì sì mi raccomando non mangiarti
la sedia o no però se tu trovi qualcosa
da mangiare portobello tanta foga ma le
due liste o pochi lo tenta mangiare
aspetto che ci penso ho detto variamo
scritto mi deconcentri lo
dovevo essere romano qua
e che cos'è questo
che cos'è uno specchio che fa apparire
più brutti ma va beh guardate costante
alligatori stai dalla parte non
concentriamoci portafortuna
che c'è proprio vedere se lo specchio
far apparire del cibo la smette di
guagnano specchio ci sono dei funghi
velenosi
mi dispiace per tempo mi sono benvenuti
quindi alla lazio mi cerca l'arma la
rotta
no non c'è niente qua si può essere
perché qua se fosse qua dentro dentro la
piscina di palline vediamo buttiamoci
balconi
non mi faccia qualcosa
ma
è ora che cosa devo fare però
ok sono prontissima ad affrontare agli
uomini non so se riuscirà a sconfiggerlo
con queste due oppure devo sbrigarmi
liberare evitare
sarà un grande tema dei maghi vieni pure
pastene ha il coraggio dei front row
attivati a combattere contro l'itas tori
dove sei arrivo a chi esce fuori con il
coraggio
eccolo non ho più paura di te anzi sei
pronto a combattere contro l'idea
abbiamo convinto
e ha speso momento devo liberare vitale
prendiamo
un grande di te ce l'ha fatta
pronti poi
[Musica]
si aspettano
a chi oa che casey misti
[Applauso]
come stanno a scuola luca strano
[Musica]
[Applauso]
il mio libro hanno rubato hanno preso
storie paurose o no a chi vuol chi lo
sta regalando a chi si missy
[Musica]
[Applauso]
dobbiamo recuperarlo dobbiamo riprendere
il mio libro si saranno rubato
[Applauso]
che schifo
se lo scarto è scoperto che siamo
[Applauso]
bega riprese tv
ho sconfitto questi mesi non ci posso
credere un conflitto vicini si ma vitale
dove e tempo lavorativo guipure presto
diamo
italia tutti qua
buio
è
meglio che mi racconto qualche metro
[Musica]
andiamo si
no
a chi molti ci ha preso presto dobbiamo
recuperare il mio libro storie paurose
voi ce l'avete l'avete preso non potete
non avere storie paurose a scolari
misteri sono dell'essere che vi
piaceranno tantissimo ora presto
svegliamoci dobbiamo entrare nell'app
l'asta influito erano kimi fiera di
nuovi a recuperare il libro non
facciamoci prendere questa volta
ricordiamo della abbiamo il car pack
dobbiamo colpire adiuvati giorni un lato
questi modelli ma va bene e la cosa mi
piace passato qualche faccia di sereno
sui 10 mila mi piace giocheremo
nuovamente abbiamo anche nella vita
reale
teniamoci presto
si il libro e con
trento o riprodurre
o no sia più grandi già preso di nuovo
dobbiamo tornare in quella classe video
poter ricavare numerosi nostro libro
facciamo così facile
[Musica]
un po
ma chi è il libro non posso vuol dire
faccio colpirlo qualche anno fa
[Musica]
prendere la mira della fortissima
servirà moltissimo che power laburismo
anni
[Applauso]
in fretta però mi sta guardando
mista guardate
che non si è mosso siccome non si muove
posso provare a prendere il libro così
secondo voi è un abolire l'uso pubblico
e va bene ci provo
[Applauso]
[Musica]
ora è rinchiuso qualcuno se mentre in
polonia
non avevamo sicuro che
ci spinge meno
forse non abbiamo sconfitto perché
l'abbiamo creato forno cosa la loro
satira non vedere usato la mano perché i
sei mesi e l'ho messa ko
eliminato biologico la mano blu chiaro
lasciamo scappare dalla scuola
dovrebbe essere qua linguaggio guarda
non c'è più
sparito
allora vuol dire che non abbiamo
eliminato vuol dire che ancora qualcuno
potrebbe essersi nascosto dietro una
porta stai attenta
no
guardate anche questa grotta si è rotta
e ora come faremmo è inutilizzabile
questo non possiamo più colpirlo si
ripetano questi non sono con questa mano
tipo così misera si pronuncino uno a
testa così si avvicina troppo
forse si arrabbierà ancora di più se
facciamo così andiamo a vedere dove la
mano blu sembrano un conflitto kiss tv
si dovrebbe esserci anche la mano
l'unicef ha permesso di nella classe zia
anche gli stilisti parità
eppure sono sicuro di averla punti
[Applauso]
e anche questi ha rotto i patti 5
ma ti sembra il momento a
scuola sì ma che torni a di monkey ma
visto che abbiamo recuperato il libro e
agli uomini non si vede più neanche gli
stilisti scappiamo direttamente riuscita
e di là però
scappiamo subito così saremo liberi
l'avremmo anche vinto la challenge si
presto andiamocene subito mia
vita
ma questa è riuscita
qui possiamo dare ma non ti sembra tutto
un po troppo
silenzioso così a 18 super semplice ma
lo
sapevo
[Applauso]
per un pelo secondo cisco ha pagato ai
più ma che per un pelo ci stavo per
prendere non nascosto di nelle scale
apposta per non farsi scappare
dobbiamo assolutamente lavorare un piano
altrimenti non riusciremo mai a scappare
da questa scuola
forse sì
non c'è più
non c'è più ma non possiamo rischiare
scendere movimenti e le scale perché lui
potrebbe sempre essere lì dobbiamo fare
una trappola in modo tale che noi ci
casca dentro non possiamo scappare via
sì ma che tipo di trappola non è facile
con adeguati e potentissimo e aspetto
momento a chi vuole il mio libro storie
paurose quindi potremo posizionare il
mio libro come esca
oppure che cosa ho un'idea che lui sta
cercando chi si missy perché innamorato
di questi mesi
facciamo finta che chi si misti e
tornata facciamo berti che fa chi si
misti e vediamo se riusciamo ad
attirarlo quale poi guarda quasi una
porta
questa volta forse si chiude cerchiamo
di capire come si chiude magari diciamo
che daranno ben entra starà ben
fantastico così noi possiamo scappare ma
presto controlla come funziona forse
guarda dice qualcosa che si muove
su vediamo
sì perciò la possiamo impressionare la
prima di allora noi si stimola questa
parte possiamo qui scavarsi dobbiamo
stare superattenti questo piano deve
funzionare al 100 per cento altrimenti
gli alti monti ci prenderei rimarremo
noi imprigionati non muovo
iniziamo con il piano kissi misti ok
faccia chi si missy ok
speriamo che funzioni ai più anni
[Musica]
arrivando continua
finta di lentini una pole ha continuato
rivisti anche
[Musica]
sì
vitale ma dove sei finito
[Musica]
ma che stai facendo
per fortuna non esiste mozione niente né
in apribile per la porta non ci credo
giorni non si sono per fortuna siamo
riusciti a fermarlo chievo vuole fare e
mi ha chiamato a collaborare a prenderci
hawking via piana
[Applauso]
[Musica]
cos'era quel rumore
andiamo a controllare presto aspetta
abbiamo
tunisi
[Applauso]
dove ci nascondiamo ci sono teca
no io vado lo stop mi sono risposto bene
così no non te nascosto per anni ben
ricordo scritto
ma che cosa vuole che cosa sta cercando
forse ci sta stai cercando noi non lo so
per quale mi vivo forse gli abbiamo
fatto qualcosa
[Musica]
è proprio cattiva
no non sto cercando noi sta cercando
qualcosa
berlino potrebbe essere pericoloso
scappa
tanto sotto il tavolo
sto cercando
semmai questi arrivato come figo
[Musica]
non mi sarei mai aspettata chicchissimi
si berlino andassero d'accordo sembrano
quasi amici
altissima sta cercando qualcosa
o no
pronunciato il libro
sta facendo lo stesso mondo con il libro
si accorge di noi sapete benissimo che
non possiamo lasciarle il libro perché
il libro dei poteri
no
perché richiesta
di brino gigante
[Applauso]
che cosa dobbiamo difenderci dobbiamo
prendere per prendere predicato queste
ecco qua ho preso
aiuto della prima tu aspettano delle
navi
[Applauso]
ho dimostrato che se messi
[Musica]
vedrà che servizi vitali ha colpito
mentre si chiedono chi dovrebbe
sentitissimi si era basta questo lo
prendo io sequestrata è questa
ma aspetta un momento ci siamo persi
qualcosa per chi si mi sentissi ma tra
il libro
[Applauso]
presto dobbiamo andare a cercarlo
prendiamo qualcosa un'arma ho preso
questo dobbiamo cercarlo assolutamente
riprendere il libro non può rimanere
nelle sue mani il libro storie paurose e
voi l'avete presto ce l'avete adesso
andiamo a prenderla che ti amo la mia
qui non c'è forse in camera da letto
issimi sì
che c'è che stiamo guardando intorno ma
se c'era chi si mischia ordinata non mi
sembra che ci sia acqua
che certo non hanno sono io mai doma il
tuo ribrezzo non vogliono connettiamo se
qua fuori dalla finestra dice che è
uscito dalla finestra in giardino
dovremo andare in giardino a prenderla
non c'è nessuno qua star ha scelto al
piano di sotto
come sappiamo 49 almeno speriamo che non
sia scappata del tutto fuori da casa
altrimenti sarà veramente difficile da
trovare riprendere il libro ha detto
questo qui nello specchio ma è sabato un
po pericoloso secondo me non mostra è
andiamocene
e proviamo a scegliere abbiamo vissuto
video mobili ok
voi l'avete vista da qualche parte della
forse meglio vedi per cento ok tu
controlli quel salotto di vado a
controllare in cucina così non rischiamo
che tu ti metti a mangiare tutte le cose
potrebbe costarle questo aspetto come
qualcosa mentre cerco magari vivere ma
aspetti naja chiede di temi hockey già
moltissimi se
non c'è
non c'è neanche qui sarà qui
no neanche qui credo che chi si messi
non si nasconda qui almeno che
neanche nell'armadio posso nascondermi
qui magari passerà a quel punto quando
passerà io sarò pronto qui a riprendermi
il libro mi metto qui comodo rispetto
che ami te mi porti qualcosa da mangiare
tanto io alla fine dovevo controllare
qui e ho controllato e problema ci sarà
mai arriverà prima o poi gli si mise o
arriverà prima o poi anita con il cibo
si arriverà aiutato il cibo
[Musica]
e chissà che
[Applauso]
cosa tutto questo rumore
[Musica]
[Applauso]
tommy avere nascondo vitale devo farla
uscire da questa stanza in qualche modo
provo a distrarla
certi un vuoto il libro per fortuna
lasciato qua lo abbiamo recuperato ma
ora dobbiamo ritrovare vitale non so
dove gli stilisti abbia nascosto vitale
c'è solo un modo per saperlo chiamare i
rinforzi per chiedere aiuto e sapete a
chi alex il google nexus
un bisogno del tuo aiuto presto è
urgentissimo vita ne è stato presto da
chi si misti la richiesta da qualche
parte ma non so dove sia chi si chi city
gli stilisti lo so forse non la conosci
perché non è nelle schede creature del
libro è una creatura diversa è una nuova
creatura un nuovo cattivo però ho
bisogno del tuo aiuto perché devo
assolutamente salvare vitale ok ok
aspetto aspetto ritenuto questa kissi
mesi che aspetto come faccio a
riconoscerlo e allora te lo spiego
subito è un pupazzo gigante così lino
molto più alto bello quanto te tu sei
alti simone perotti poco di fuori è
tutta rosa ed è pelota rosa rosa peloso
auto ok una femmina aver capito se sì lo
so che dalla descrizione sembra qualcosa
di supercar inoltre nero a ti assicuro
che quando la vedrai ti farà paura voto
perché ha un sorriso molto polemico e
poi vuole mandarci
bene molto bene contro lei e poi un giro
in casa che gironzola e si sta cercando
ok ok pochino che adesso adesso non
facciamoci prendere dal bari dal non
facciamoci vedere la parco ok allora
pensiamo che siamo io non la conosco non
è una creatura di libro io non so cosa
possiamo fare poi libro magari a una
risposta a una soluzione non saprei io
credo che l'unica soluzione sia che la
pro di zucchero
lo sapete io odio
non me lo sento e poi ce ne sono allora
sono esattamente le giudicare persone
sono le cinque quindi io tengo scapole
un impegno io non voglio andar mattei
vento nuovo mezzo lupo agli atti ne è
tutto non posso affrontarla io è troppo
forte per me e magari tu riuscirebbe a
farlo non lo so sì ma mezzo uomo e mezzo
gruppo ma sono né uno né l'altro almeno
sei tutto si in tutta umana a cui fare
ed io non me la sento poi m5 io prendo
il tè subitamente prendo quindi
gradi cina caffè vabbè grazie per il non
aiuto l'ex
vai pure a prendere the e arrangiarmi è
sconfiggere che significa solo che mi
dispiace quindi io non posso aiutarti da
come viene descritta si sembra un
pochino un pericolo un po troppo grande
e quindi
perdonami aiuta in questo caso lo saprei
proprio come aiutati quindi se siamo a
posto io andrei credevo che i lupi
fossero più che ragiona ancora però
detto
non è paura e di comprendere il termine
5 qui certo vai pure una giornata
comunque ciao
e propria scappato possibile che anche
l'ex abbia paura di chi si misti non ha
neanche mai vista ho un'idea forse del
libro troverò comunque qualche risposta
anche se non c'è la scheda creatura di
chi si missy avete lasciato un mi piace
mi raccomando lasciate un mi piace qui
sotto
vediamo se troviamo qualcosa
ma
aiuto
[Applauso]
[Musica]
che schifo
lei e chi si
sa più di me
aiutami
a
[Musica]
un passo da anche cosa vuoi e
allora adesso io cercherò di aiutarti ma
fatta di gesti e bondi non
[Musica]
generano
aiutavi sconfigge la in qualche modo
lo so
[Musica]
credo credo che gli piaccia sì credo che
tu le piaccia
si
sta comportando in modo molto strano non
sei proprio il mio tipo no dico la
verità ai troppi più peruzzi di me
guarda guarda guarda te
mi sembra che agli stilisti inutili pre
di niente che tu non vuoi
[Musica]
ma cosa mi tocca fare questo al bar di
abilità grazie se la mettono giù non sta
succedendo cosa ha preso
è un regalo
ho deciso di partire per me questo per
me
sarai anche brutti ha però sei molto
dolce
[Applauso]
sì ma è comunque non è il mio tipo si
pronto
[Musica]
a piogge no niente non voglio aggiungere
troppi d'italia
accetto però tu non mi mangi va bene non
mi hanno
detto no
no no
carini
[Musica]
ok
siamo qua
[Musica]
ho capito ho capito che piace
davvero mi dispiace per te l'ex ma è
veramente divertente questa situazione
non mi sarei mai aspettata che gli
stilisti si sarebbe innamorata di te
come pensi che possiamo fare allora può
essere un vantaggio perché se le
innamorata di te non ti farò del male
credo puoi fare finta di essere
innamorato di lei e poi tu che conosci
molto bene i poteri del libro storie
paurose cui trovare un incantesimo un
qualcosa che che la faccia sparire o
qualcosa del genere però l'importante è
che lei non capisca che tu stai cercando
di eliminarla altrimenti si arrabbierà
tantissimo ok ok ho un'idea fiato di
potersi liberare più gli artigli
ciao ciao
non capisco cosa stia facendo
mi ha detto di martinetti ha messo
qualcosa qui dentro vuole che abito io
che cosa vuoi fare
sì non mi piace troppo l'idea
credo che se non la vedi io figlio molto
male anche vitale che non sappiamo
ancora dove rinchiuso quindi è meglio
meno bene va bene va bene molta fatica
ma dei
reati che ti sbrighi
grazie l'ex ministro criticate ad aver
bevuto
quell'intrico tenta ora questi miti
disgustosa lei come ti senti l'ex non
sento nessun cambiamento
credo fosse un tè uno di quelli un pò
esotici ah ok meno male non era niente
di strano tipo una pozione veleno forte
veleno
ha detto che finiti ma è meglio che il
pilota è normale che anche se lei un po
malefica non so che cosa ti ha
architettato con quali io sono qui per
lavoro faccio finta di essere ancora
legate al momento giusto scappiamo bravo
proprio come da piano conto sul tuo
aiuto l'ex mi raccomando tu sarai
fondamentale tube massai a me piace
stare qui i conti sinisi
ma che stai dicendo lei che finissi ma
la lista è bellissima e bellezza
è in crisi ho sentito un abbraccio
l'ex impazzito di aver trovato l'amore
della mia vita perché mi ci si è visti
il pupazzo candido
[Musica]
o no che cosa è successo all'ex forse
queste che ho bevuto di ha fatto
qualcosa
[Musica]
ma ci teniamo tantissimo forse lei ha
preparato una pozione d'amore perché chi
stimi si vedeva che alex non era
minimamente interessato a lei ce
l'andremo ci dovremmo una bellissima
vita insieme
che schifo
soluzione una libro deve farlo tanto che
simili e molto distratta adesso dall'ex
creare un antidoto con il libro
non sono brava come l'ex né gli
incantesimi con libro ma ci provo libro
vai tornare l'ex normale se normale
credo che sia successo qualcosa forse
questo è l'antidoto oppure potrebbe
essere qualcosa di mostruoso che fa
trasformare sia chi si mesi che l'ex ma
speriamo che sia l'antidoto è ora devo
stare a trovare il modo di farlo bene
alex
m.lev
c'è chi si visti entrambi
anziché selis ti senti non hai paura che
l'effetto della pozione d'amore svanisca
beh se svanisce un gran problema perché
l'ex si ricorderà che le fai schifo
quindi è meglio che metteva alcuno
pochettino non credi
anche dall ex boy berne altra vero vuoi
essere ancora più innamorato di casey
visti vero
[Risate]
è lì e lì pronta dai debiti
[Applauso]
si bravo bravissimo bravissimo che se mi
sento nino marino ridondanti significhi
subito
questo ed altro
un po meno male speriamo che faccia a
faccia subito cisco amore mio
[Applauso]
amico
mi ha fatto un incantesimo non
finalmente trasformata in quello che è
un pupazzo
[Applauso]
ce l'abbiamo fatta
adesso non potrà più farci del male o
troppo forti
ce l'ha
[Musica]
aiutato l'incantesimo del libro ma ora
dobbiamo dobbiamo liberare in italia non
sappiamo su pepito liberiamoci di chris
christie addio
andiamo a cercare di tale vero andiamo
andiamo ci potra guidare
bidone
ciao ciao amico l'ex soprattutto quando
soccorso grazie ho fatto io lo sconfitto
io ce l'ho fatta non sempre porta dentro
che cosa avete fatto
ma adesso non fa più paura anzi
ho sempre schifo
grazie all'incantesimo del libro alex
riuscito a sconfiggere chi si misti e
trasformarla in un botto e voi l'avete
già preso scrivetevi
[Applauso]
[Musica]
sì sì
sì
[Applauso]
sì sì
[Musica]
ciao circi
piano piano
dai di nuovo mangiando di nascosto o no
che cosa te lo fa pensare fai vedere
certamente guarda non c'è niente di ho
detto non c'è dietro gli ho detto
è quello che cos'è è un sono i
croccantini di berlino vedi
lo sapevo che stava nascondendo del cibo
dai dargli un pò che a me adesso almeno
noto lo fanno per me berlino
che cos'era
qualcuno ha chiuso la porta e qualcuno
ha chiuso la porta a chiave ma sono
stato il vento guarda la tabella dei
colori voi avete capito vero e la
tabella dei colori di pofi playtime si
sa chi vuol chi ora dobbiamo trovare la
combinazione di colori giusta per uscire
da questa stanza o no preferisco
mangiare a casa ma è vero un bel cracker
[Musica]
guardiamoci poi intorno per trovare i
colori ad esempio uno dei colori può
essere celeste un verde c'è anche il blu
qui o trance le stelle e anche rosa
guarda l'orologio quindi forse sarà
verde celeste blu rosa ok proviamo
presto quindi abbiamo detto verbeck
celeste blu blu e rosa ferrosa
tempo romanismo bravo
ci sarà chi vuol kiko fuori prima di
scoprirlo dobbiamo dirvi una cosa
importante svolto tantissimo che
vogliamo dirvelo per annunciarvi lo vi
facciamo prima vedere il trailer e poi
vi spieghiamo meglio pronti per il
trailer in 32 una b
[Musica]
un mistero da svelare
4 misteriose creature da scoprire
un'avventura che vi lascerà col fiato
sospeso
storie paurose a scuola di misteri e ora
disponibile per il pre ordine su amazon
[Musica]
sto cavolo di di spendere il mio libro è
ora disponibile
su amazon siamo troppo
felici è un sogno che si avvera non
vedevamo l'ora di dirt non metteva
motore tdi
[Risate]
farlo già più paurose alcuno di misteri
è la storia di quattro ragazzini due
ragazzi di due ragazzine che si chiamano
lei o tommaso mina e alyssa compagni di
classe certo punto a scuola arriva una
su sull'ente molto misteriosa è molto
strana che assegna loro una ricerca su
delle creature miss poi loro che le
creature sono le nostre e le vostre
preferite sarebbe risponderà solo due il
lupo banda lo è i vampiri di loro
dovranno andare a cercare queste
creature ma dovranno anche risolvere un
mistero e anche voi potrete risolvere il
mistero infatti a me allora anche se non
vi piace tanto leggere vi assicuro che
questo libro vi terrà incollati
alle pagine fino alla fine perché vi
tiene col fiato sospeso volete sapere
cosa succede in ogni storia per ogni
storia che leggerete accumulerete dei
punti e alla fine del libro in base ai
punti che avrete accumulato potrete
leggere a quale profilo a partner e
super divertente come se farete anche
voi una challenge partecipate anche voi
a lasciarle insieme ai protagonisti
mai più solo per i primissimi
preordini
libro da cartolina autografata da me
evitare quindi preordinate subito il
libro storie paurose a scuola di misteri
vedrete che vi appassionerà tantissimo
non riuscirete a smettere di leggerlo
cliccate nel link in descrizione per pre
ordinarlo su amazon se l'avete
preordinato scrivetelo nei commenti ma
ora presto continuiamo nella nostra sala
zia
avete visto
dobbiamo con tornare lì
credo proprio di sì che importante che
non meno 11 con cucina
[Applauso]
quando tutte le mie cose
permesso ma come la nostra che
vediamo
cos'è questo
l'esperimento sul giocattolo è fallito
lui
verrà a cercarvi
trova il fiore
poppy playtime lui verrà a cercarmi
ecco perché qua in casa nostra o forse
il fiore si mangia forse edibile questo
figlio e lo si può mangiare
cosa il grande bach
vediamo come funziona che
è bellissimo
svetta manca la mano ecco la mano
abbiamo l'amalgama non manca la mano
destra da trovare wow e se non avete
ancora lasciato mi piace lasciate un mi
piace perché se questo video raggiunge i
15 mila bts giocheremo anche con chi si
miti nella vita reale lascia di un mi
piace qua entro 5 secondi come
32 una caduta
vediamo se funziona
batti il cinque sono sicuro
[Musica]
per poco e non ha funzionato devi
battere ci
batte in cinque
è troppo divertente questo gran parte
subito trovare la mano rossa adesso
presto parliamo guardate c'è qualcosa
via alla porta
per sbloccare la porta si vado
prossimo carta tv premuto
sabato
più anche
o no che cosa
facciamo adesso sempre immobile
perché credo che dobbiamo attivare
l'elettricità come nel videogioco
guarda io ho un impegno un impegno che a
preziosi vice all l'impegno ha lasciato
il corso prevede un finire troppo paura
la vado a mangiare scuse bene so ciao
evitare proprio un fifone ci penso io a
risolvere costa challenge
innanzitutto cerchiamo una mano rossa
tanto ora a khimki non dovrebbe muoversi
vero
the dead
se ora
proverò utilizzare il gran pac magari
così si sveglia 31
si è mosso di un millimetro
guardate un altro simbolo della mano
devo aprire la porta con il mio grande
pac ehi avete lasciato un mi piace se
non avete ancora lasciato cliccate mi
piace quando
avete sentito
sono comparse richiami che vedrete
presto prendiamo con il dottor raffa
ok ora che ho le chiavi proviamo ad
aprire la porta
maggie non puoi farmi niente addio
la mano rossa la mano destra
ora il mio grappa che completo
ma al di là di
dove sei finito forse è salito al piano
di sopra capitale è meglio che lo vito
vitale
succede a chi moriva su presunte stucco
subito fretta ho puntato molto sulla
mangiamare 20 addio felice i cracker non
so magari che stava portando su qualcosa
da mangiare no non c'è niente da
mangiare non è questo momento è sparito
qua ho trovato un amaro delle strade ora
dobbiamo trovare il quadro elettrico io
sotto per quadro elettrico posso
aiutarti torniamo credo che bisogna
coprirlo con entrambe le mani però degli
homo funzioni
siamo
pure la fortuna ma non è che c'è chi
guardi qui no e non credo come
toccherebbe
sbrigati
ok ora che hai attivato l'elettricità
dobbiamo cercare il fiore io ho davvero
disappunto piaciuto qui come
se nessuno
poi avete visto qualcuno qua
no non c'è nessuno mi serve
di guardì
[Musica]
c'è nessuno
gli uomini non equa al piano di sopra
spero che non sia al piano di sotto con
vitale senza il grand pas capitale non
riuscirà mai a difendersi dagli waki
anzi magari proverà a offrirli del cibo
beh non mi resta che controllare in
corridoio di là allora anche se è molto
buio e il cirs hai visto di luoghi da
qualche parte
e
no circe sta guardando di lama di la
loggia controllato non c'è niente
vabbè magari se n'è andato via
dove sarà il fiore
con in coma non ho visto nessun fiore
forse è meglio se chiamo vitale perché
oggi luoghi potrebbe essere al piano di
sotto con lui
[Musica]
beh ora fa dice no ma che è successo
o duty è già preso forse era tutto un
sogno
no a giudicare da quel suono no cav
ivovic ha preso abbiamo perso la prima
partita ma adesso abbiamo un'altra
possibilità dobbiamo trovare subito il
fioretto che potrà essere penso il fiore
possa essere in giardino o no i cori si
trovano in certi lo è di certo non in
casa va beh tu vai a controllare in
giardino io contro il corridoio buio che
dice prossima idea capito che i ragazzi
mettiamo per esplorare il corridoio buio
speriamo di trovare il fiore
seleziona
che cos'è
il fiore
e i fiori
abbiamo trovato il quorum
ora possiamo completare la salsiccia
[Musica]
ma io il fiore forse devo regalarlo a
lui
bene
e a chi wang yi
[Musica]
mi sa tanto che non mi fai piu paura
adesso
[Musica]
e così carino ritrova guarda ho trovato
solo questi
[Musica]
ho già trovato io in fiore dove agiva
chi adesso stai per schiacciarlo
schiacciarlo guarda
[Musica]
era questo l'obiettivo della missione
trovare il fiore perché pisolino così fa
ciao ciao milioni di giochi moglie ora
non puoi più fare del male a nessuno
[Musica]
ti abbiamo sconfitto ormai a chi va chi
non ci fai piu paura non
possiamo anche lasciarlo andare tanto
ora non farà mai del male a nessuno no
così piccolo ciao ciao
è chiuso dobbiamo trovare la
combinazione di colori per aprirlo come
del videogioco onesto colore giusto è
pieno di colori potrebbero essere tutti
i colori guardiamoci bene intorno sono
tantissimi colori o no vado sardi a
proposito grazie dodò parti per averci
ospitati di nuovo bellissimo qua c'è
qualcosa qui anche qui una pallina verde
e io ho trovato una pallina gialla
ceniamo layout si guarda forse ne una
rosa non lo sue trecce mancazzo lunga
continua meglio può niente qui
si
direbbe rosa giallo rosso verde rosa
giallo
[Musica]
ma tube il libro il mio libro da fa
specie più produrre idea
perché innanzitutto dobbiamo trovare il
gran pack 0 prima di avvicinarsi ad aghi
wak in almeno avremmo qualcosa per
difendersi tutto il resto guardiamo poi
toro dove potrebbe essere
poi vediamo guarda c'è una mano giu
prima
a produrla bruno allora dobbiamo solo
trovare 37 arriva corpo io guardo fatto
sto facendo la giocata
che
siamo pronti a difendersi da di quattro
sono d'accordo
ecco fatto siamo ora al dynamo arrivando
a prenderci il libro il nostro libero
adesso mi spaventano subito batte 5
3 capito
timore non ti muovere o ti batti il
cinque con queste non si sta movendo non
vedi che immobile anzi non ti ricordi
quello che dobbiamo fare dobbiamo
attivarli elettricità sono così che si
muoverà e poi potremo trovare libro
storie paurose o dacci le chiavi della
sosta dell'attività hai capito e tanto
di juan g non ci fai paura che
è che mi ha accarezzato
credo che sia meglio non provocarlo che
è
attrezzato anche juan che non volevamo
di tre parti rimane pure lì immobile
presto dobbiamo trovare la stanza delle
lepri sito lui con lui possiamo attivare
l'elettricità per lui andrà via e
potremo riprendere il nostro libro
giusto
forse questo
guarda c'è un pochino perché solo chiedo
devo trovare una chiave qualcosa
perdiamo ad aprirla al diavolo
dimmi una combinazione allora potrebbe
essere la mia famiglia serata linguaggio
riguardi potrebbe piacere il 123 euro
vado a cercare una soluzione forse
nell'altra sala perché non puoi
lasciarmi solo con queste cose
tecnologiche io voi dopo non ci capisco
più niente
ad esempio quello potrebbe essere numero
di hacking però per poter aprire il
lucchetto potrebbe essere uno due tre
grazie
non pensavo fosse così siamo martellati
aspetta un atto io voglio per una volta
gli immobili ha mandato questo non c'è
una grande
ed ho aperto nucetto ce l'ha fatto
troppo guardava parte lucchetto
certo adesso allora qual è il numero
numero era a vedere il numero aspettiamo
23 era facile no
il numero di adeguati 123 no come mai
quasi un altro numero e bombe perché nel
frattempo si sarà spostato
importante che la porterebbe
[Musica]
cosa dobbiamo fare foto mai dover
attivare l'elettricità
forse c'è un altro enigma da risolvere
qua per attivare l'elettricità a tremiti
ma e poi potrebbe essere non lo so
vediamo questo verde giallo verde blu
cementare difficilissimo cardani abbiamo
bisogno ma che ha bisogno del filo di
voce c'è un bambino inglese sono troppi
e le 24
sicuramente rimane un sacco di tempo mi
piace esplorare il cervello ma cercava
di mare pescati
e
attivato l'elettricità sì ho risolto
l'enigma bastava semplicemente
accenderemo l'invito l'interruttore ed
ecco l'elettricità
[Applauso]
guarda presto dove dobbiamo andare per
estate fatto di quanto lo scopo luoghi è
sparito quindi sicuramente sarà dentro
alla fabbrica di giocattoli
però dobbiamo assolutamente entrare il
prima possibile per recuperare il nostro
lista che ha detto ai rumori perché non
lo so potrebbe essere che si nascondeva
dietro libro
che
sto per dire le mani nel club pac ma non
puoi fare così ogni volta verrà a
prenderci avuto paura allora
quanti si professi mo
anno devo prendere altrimenti con che
cosa si difendiamo c'è ragione un'ottima
idea vado subito a ricaricare il club
bach non ti preoccupare io ricarica
tappate arrivati ci sia vivo remo
aspetta come si fa questo adesso perché
faccio sole stornando difenderti lo
predomino con campagna
vedi quell'ombra no non vedo niente c'è
qualcosa che si è mosso per laggiù in
fondo forse oggi luoghi giù che ci
aspetta sa bene quindi siamo sicuro qui
se non siamo proprio al sicuro qua
dentro però dobbiamo sbrigarci per
recuperare il nostro libro sarà
d'accordo ho fatto prima io vado
sono caduto mai stava perdendo sono
rotolato
ma qua c'è lo sciopero non si può salire
da qua bisogna fare il genero e salire
dalla stoffa 9 fare il giro siamo qui
basta salito dallo scivolo dice la
parola stessa scivolo cioè no aspetta
quel fallire no questo esce ci va bene
insomma si chiede poi si fa prima da te
fai come vuoi ci vediamo dopo la sua
operazione ok va bene ciao c'è problema
io salgo da qui mica faccio tutto il
giro si sale di qualche ci vuole tanto
lo dice la parola stessa ci vuole cioè
nel senso non è che era così difficile
uno si mette qui cammina un po e piano
piano sale no piano piano sale piano
piano tale anche se volendo
effettivamente si scivola e si è una
scivolata male che si scivola vitale
thain genio
perché non ti ascolto mai ora militare
in giro e si celebra l'ultima volta che
vedo è d'aiuto
no non ha funzionato dai sbrigati a
linda guarda te l'ho detto che ce
l'avrei fatta non mi sembra proprio che
ce l'hai fatta
aiuto aiuto aiuto aiuto aiuto
sempre il solito
fatto in giro per non ci passa più
fallita
meriterebbe una mano qui dove ho detto
che stai mangiando troppo però non ci
portino avanti
ho chiesto a stretta tira tira con tutta
giovani
devo
proprio andare di qua in questi tubi
forse quando riusciremo a trovare il
libro
avete sentito
lasciate un mi piace per portarci
fortuna ti forse c'è qualcosa in uno di
questi tubi
momento di quella casetta li
aspettano di essere preso due ci guardi
via libera non c'è nessuno cuore almeno
credo a meno che non sia nascosto da
qualche parte che
è solo rotolato ok forse è meglio se
andiamo nell'altra area prima che arrivi
a dualchi ok sarà più a chi però non lo
so forse ci sta già cercando forse
dobbiamo superare quegli ostacoli league
guarda tutti questi moduli attivati lui
prima erano 38 posto prima io o privato
vado prima io vado prima io tu stai
attento a non inciampare però è perché
pensano stai attenta potrebbe essere
molto pericoloso ha capito
ma per ora è già cantaroni già bari non
avevo visto che c'era quel coso lì e
sono inciampato
o impossibile ci casco proprio questo
si fa con ninja insomma carige rotolante
come non c'è un modo di disattivarli e
no
questi sono quelli animali e questi mesi
brava ci hai fatto apre così dobbiamo
andare allora io penso che cosa vedono
scivolo e l'unica strada o no porterà
c'è un altro scivolo troppo qua non
abbiamo trovato i pro quindi dobbiamo
tornare giù
italiani ieri dai punta di boot di muffa
non voglio scendere dallo scivolo non
c'è un'altra zona
metri ei metodi guerra
vitale betti rapallo
e va bene vuoi la guerra è guerra
tutti
[Musica]
pecca di questo
io devo solo vedere
se
possiamo lottare
questo ci sta provando davvero
eventi come le spalle
a chi nati
anche la morozzo
non più tardi no
scambiamo voglio ritrovarmi in arrivo a
chi vuoi che non lo vedo più dove sarei
andato si è presentato l'importante che
non stia arrivando qua no no ce la
possiamo fare adesso non è che magari
qua ma no era lì un attimo fa scopa con
dei capi non c'è più e non l'ho visto
che non c'era portati bene intorno anche
voi controllate che oggi luoghi non sia
fatta taiz negativo che abbiamo detto
noi dobbiamo trovare il libro si si si
come vedi il libro da qualche parte no
ma andiamo di qua
sono sicuro questa
valida arma
da taglio che giganti aiuto che ha paura
che paura
ah no è un peluche
era solo peluche come un vero e non lo
so perché mi sono spaventato perché
pensavo fosse qualche anno i foja guangi
che che magari ci vuole ci vuole
impedire di prendere il libro mi hai
fatto spaventare te lo dico io cosa
serve quel plus poi sono stato a dire
ma questo è vero cio che serve per
attivare la fabbrica dei giocattoli di
adeguati
ora dobbiamo solo trovare il rullo
trasportatore dei giocattoli per
attivare la fabbrica e mettere questo
peluche così accederemo la prossima area
forse riusciamo finalmente a recuperare
il mio libro attori e paurose andiamo
dobbiamo dare di qua sicuramente se
abbiamo trovato il peluche lancio su un
altro scivolo forse qualcuno della
fabbrica ma per accedere lì non dobbiamo
salire su dobbiamo tornare giù credo
questo vediamo si ri primo
prima che arrivi a di voi che non la
vita ti stai sbagliando dobbiamo andare
lì no quindi la che si scende per
arrivare qua non si può bastare anche da
sotto facciamo una gara sì io passo da
sotto a due passi da sto per chi arriva
prima a vita è
[Applauso]
inaccettabile
però ecco quel passaggio per accedere
allo scivolo
vediamo vediamo si è fatto prima e
vitale no
ma quindi sei arrivata prima di me è
parecchio prima stavo già schiacciando
un pisolino e allora beta di questo ma
insomma non si scherza non devi far
scivolare il giocattolo dallo scivolo in
questo modo potremo attivare la fabbrica
io non ho sentito nessun rumore
aspetta aspetta milan ce io così faccio
un botto enorme ok
non so se siamo riusciti ad attivare la
fabbrica dovremo salire al piano di
sopra per capire se sta funzionando la
fabbrica
[Musica]
ok dobbiamo trovare il libro il prima
possibile ho sentito dei botti ho paura
che la tv chi si stia avvicinando questa
sala e grandissimo dove potrebbe essere
guardiamo si fa intorno
ma è proprio sembrato di sentire dei
passi in alto magari proprio qui nel
tubo aspetta un attimo guarda
guardatelo giu ma l'anno scorso io se
fosse solo una trappola per attirarci là
sopra e poi ci prende guarda la monodia
kimoni o no non è una trappola dobbiamo
per forza a salire la sopra a recuperare
il libro lo so che sicuramente si sarà
di walkie ma magari riusciremo comunque
a non essere presi presto andiamo anche
noi tiriamo gli occhi aperti anche voi
state molto attenti dobbiamo prendere il
libro riesco a vederlo che la quale
proprio in questo tubo sei proprio lì e
occhi vuoti dove sarò e
non si vede ancora non si vede qua
speriamo che non spunti fuori
all'improvvisa dei ma è proprio qui che
dobbiamo dare noi su questo tubo che mi
sembra di vedere niente dentro al tubo
quindi a chirurghi non è dentro al tubo
e da qualche altra parte si scopriranno
quanto bramito che c'è a scorta ha
capito qualcosa
ho sentito dei passi proprio qua sopra
quindi forse emesse stato preparò una
sbirciatina per vedere se c'è anche il
controllo e poi fammi sapere
sembra tutto ok ho qui all'inter e
allora andiamo dai significati a
montecatini che mi ha votato
addio a pisa preso abbiamo rifatto tutto
il percorso ora risaliamo la forte
prendiamo sto per me essere qua alla
fine di questo tubo al libro
sentito i rumori del caso no non sono
rumore quindi non penso che sia un
perfetto
quindi qualcosa da lì
no non c'è niente devo solo percorrere
tutto il tubo è prendere il libro io
vado a prendere in giro io sono dietro
di te andiamo andiamo
uffa kimoni già preso di nuovo siamo
risaliti qua all'ultimo piano orari
proviamo a prendere il libro dal tubo
sperando che oggi luoghi non sia ancora
qua ma non sento nessun rumore questa è
l'ultima volta
che
vai a prenderlo su questa volta va in
soccorso provato io ok
via libera ok andiamo mai non dovevo
dare
che ci sono video controllare per
prendere ripresa abbiamo finalmente
scappare da questa fabbrica dei
giocattoli di che cos'è questo rumore
servizio a tutte le sei accorta
sappiamo tutti ma immobili
stai dicendo di no ha detto no non l'uno
partiamo direttamente dall'albero
partiamo dal blue me e anche col 2
allora facciamo che al 3 prendiamo che
scattiamo e il provino proprio
[Musica]
[Applauso]
[Risate]
una busta di prestiti non mi succede
come se siamo in una talea della
fabbrica
facciamo gli sprechi
doveva essere poi questo blog visto che
nell'altra sala era ad entrare blog non
lo vedo però vale la pena cercare
andiamo e tv presso andiamo
[Musica]
[Applauso]
io ti aiuto un pò tito schivo che qua
è scappato aiuto
aiuto story posto
si
no sono titoli
di qualità
massimo
ecco
la top
20 di questo giovane
no no
no
velocità se mi sono fatto
capolino
[Applauso]
sui diritti negati
prima mi si sblocchi oggi luoghi presto
un piano proviamo a far cadere kimwaki
da qua si è forse riusciremo a vincere
la zona quindi speriamo di riuscirci
tutti i palati non lo può solo che lo
chiamiamo
un'idea mettiamoci questo prassi in
piedi e chiamiamolo haghighi non ci pare
niente schiappa
perdente 6 anche goffo e interventi
si sta
arrivando
[Musica]
speriamo che il nostro biglietto è
arrabbiatissimo
aspetto è stato
attivato questo
[Musica]
[Applauso]
giusto
ma dobbiamo ancora trovare il libro
dobbiamo trovare fiore organi papavero
il poppi presto ci vediamo se siamo solo
noi non abbiamo ancora controllato in
questa tu contro la prima che la meglio
della piscina delle palline io non lo so
ma non credo che ci sia niente
quando qualcosa dai tu no infatto
blocchetto o no non c'è niente dobbiamo
cercare il piano guarda bene tutte le
immagini l'aspetta il gruppo il bruco
alle volte mancano anche i fiori o
sbaglio sì forse siamo felici sì come
potrebbe essere
guarda
di papavero poppi quindi il libro di là
che sta dentro
niente ma che lo vedo da
ora disponibili
correte subito a prenderlo non riuscire
a trasmettere diventano perché li terrei
con le immagini non apriremo e ci sono
anche delle creature fantastiche le
scoprirete tutti all'interno del libro
correte a vederlo lasciate un bel mi
piace storia questo video e ora vi
lasciamo 4 casilina su cui cliccare per
vedere inoltre altri video cliccate su
quella che preferite